welcome back to Piers Morgan uncensored
a rather rare in fact unique uh work
from home addition of Pi Morgan uncensor
because I am currently suffering from
covid but we'll man up and crack on I'm
with Professor Neil Ferguson U Neil I
want to talk to you about two Wars let's
start with Israel and Gaza and what is
going on there I I've spoken a lot in
the last two months about feeling a real
moral quandry about this in the sense I
feel that Israel is absolutely morally
Justified to defend itself from future
attacks of the kind we saw in October
the 7th and if fact has a duty to defend
its people given that Hamas has said
they want to keep doing it again and
again and again and they're a terror
group who will clearly do that um but
when you see the scale of what is going
on in Gaza the displacement of well over
a million people now the the the
leveling of most of Northern Gaza and
now they're heading into the South to do
the same and the increasingly shocking
death toll of civilians and in
particular children in a place where
half the population are children you
know I I'm beginning to have like most
people who who defend Israel's right to
defend itself a real moral quam about
the scale of of their retribution which
is how many people see it what do you
think well I don't think it's just
retribution I think it's clear uh that
Israel can no longer coexist with Hamas
in control of Gaza uh if anybody doubted
that then those doubts were surely
spelled on October the 7th with the most
hideous scenes of violence against Jews
since the Holocaust indeed it seemed to
me that what Hamas were really trying to
communicate was their intention to
reenact the Holocaust and I think every
one of us regardless of whether we're
Jewish or not has a moral obligation to
ensure that there never is another
Holocaust and those who threaten to wipe
Israel uh from the map uh are intending
nothing less than a second Holocaust so
the issue is can Hamas uh be destroyed
as it should be at at an an acceptable
cost uh it's the same question that had
to be asked uh when British and American
forces were uh fighting an Insurgency uh
in Iraqi cities it's the same question
that had to be asked when uh it was
Islamic State uh that was being wiped
out and since these uh organizations
specialize in concealing themselves in
densely populated Urban centers uh it's
inconceivable that they can be defeated
at zero cost uh to civilians uh now the
problem for Israel is that it's damned
whatever it does if it uh If It Moves
civilians out of the way it's accused of
ethnic cleansing if it doesn't it's
hypocritically accused uh of genocide uh
so this is a a very very difficult
indeed welln impossible situation and
it's not made any easier when the
International Community and indeed the
US government leans on Israel uh to stop
or pause or cease fire because that only
allows Hamas to regroup and it almost
certainly prolongs the conflict I want
to add another Point pier this is not
just about Gaza it's also about the
other areas where Israel is under attack
uh it's about the unstable situation in
the West Bank uh it's about the
possibility that at any moment Hezbollah
could launch a massive bombardment of
rockets and missiles uh from Lebanon in
into Israel and and there's more because
there are also all kinds of uh forces in
Syria that bear ill will towards Israel
the war has the potential to escalate
and grow in multiple ways we're in a
kind of lull at the moment incredible
though it may seem to say that and my
fear is that at some point in the coming
weeks we'll see the next phase of the
war and new front will be opened up and
Israel will be fighting not only in Gaza
but potentially elsewhere uh for its
very survival and I want to underline to
your viewers given the very small size
uh of Israel and its vulnerability in a
neighborhood where it's almost entirely
surrounded by hostile forces its very
survival is at stake uh so I think it's
very important particularly for people
in Britain and the us not to be swayed
by the very clever propaganda that comes
out uh of Gaza often uh Hamas crafted
often Hamas authorized which is designed
to make you think there's some moral
equivalence here uh because there really
can't be moral equivalence when Israel
is retaliating for the appalling attacks
of October the 7th and that is a just
war that is being fought right now is
war ever clean no are there civilian
casualties in War nearly always
particularly in modern times that's the
reality and I'm afraid uh we have more
to face of this harsh reality because
this war is only like likely to escalate
in the coming
weeks how does it end I mean you're
historian you you have covered many
conflicts and Wars um I I just worry
about whether Israel has an end game
here that doesn't just involve in many
of their eyes in the leadership just
taking over Gaza for example occupying
it completely going forward do you see
anything other than that happening
well there's no great appetite uh within
the Israeli military for an occupation
of Gaza because they have bitter
memories of uh of what that was like
before and indeed what other occupations
that the Israeli Army the Israeli
Defense Forces have have carried out in
the past but who has a better idea at
this point it's a little difficult to
imagine uh the dust settling and a new
uh Force emerging to take the place of
Hamas that isn't just as is bad it's not
like the Palestinian Authority is about
to be put back in charge of Gaza
everybody knows that Palestinian
Authority is an oxymoron those two words
no longer meaningfully Belong Together
there are some other options which I
think need to be considered uh after all
what's the United Nations for if it's
not to send blue helmets into dangerous
territories where the alternative is
ongoing conflict and that seems to me to
be the kind of thing that should be
under much more serious disc discussion
at the moment
internationalizing Gaza U that seems the
kind of uh end game that would make much
more sense to me than an Israeli
occupation that would almost certainly
just become a a succession of of
terrorist attacks and counter
measures yeah I agree um just want to
turn briefly to Ukraine because
obviously Ukraine has almost been
forgotten at the moment at a very
worrying time if you're president
zalinski with American Financial support
for their military Endeavors looking
like it's pretty perilous in terms of
future uh Financial input where are we
with this Ukraine war is it as some
people fear now inevitable that there
will have to be some kind of deal that
involves Putin swallowing up some if not
all of the land that he has barbarically
stolen well Pierce 20 years ago I I
wrote a book called American Colossus
and I argued there that one of the
problems of American power is the
attention deficit disorder that kicks in
usually uh after a couple of years of
any engagement and even when the
engagement isn't one that involves
American troops in the front line and
sure enough American interest has been
on the Wayan uh in the course uh of the
last uh several months to the point that
there are real question marks over the
continuation of American Aid and
American Aid is pretty crucial uh both
militarily and financially in the U in
the European Union too uh as well as in
the UK one has the sense and a Ukrainian
friend said this to me yesterday that
people's interest has just wondered my
friend was saying that the CNN operation
in keev has been relocated to the Middle
East as a kind of symbol that a new
story is in town and the old stories no
longer really getting the ratings this
is very concerning for any friend of
Ukraine and I consider myself a stonch
friend uh of Ukraine I've been to that
country almost every year for the past
decade because the scenario isn't in
conceivable that they could lose this
war Russians are amassing Firepower they
have greater raw resources they have the
capacity to launch an air war against
Ukraine uh in the coming weeks that
could paralyze Ukraine's uh electricity
system if it's successful uh and so it's
not so much that there's going to be
some nasty compromise deal I don't think
President Putin's interested in
negotiation he's playing for higher
Stakes because he senses that the
politics in the west is going his way
way and he has a shot at Victory if he's
patient and that's the thing that really
concerns me we sort of lost interest
we're focused on the next War the next
Shiny Bright objects and while we're not
paying attention we could see Ukraine
defeated and Pi Piers mark my words if
Ukraine is defeated that will send a
signal not only to Putin it'll send a
signal to xianping in China it'll send a
signal to the iats in Iran it'll send a
signal to pongyang to North Korea and
the signal will be the West is weak it
can canot sustain its commitments it
can't even hold uh Ukraine up in the
face of a Russian attack and that will
spell the beginning of a very dark age
in which the 2020s will start to feel
enough a lot like the 1930s so the
stakes are extremely high and I urge
people do not lose interest in Ukraine
it is vitally important that Russia not
win this
war absolutely it's about freedom and
democracy and we used to go to world
wars to preserve and defend that and
it's terrifying to me see so many people
who are prepared to let Putin take what
he's what he's
stolen